data protection is a concern for many EU
citizens be it when using social
networks buying products online or
simply surfing the web most people want
to be sure that their personal data will
not be improperly used EU ministers of
Justice have been working on a proposal
to ensure high protection of personal
data across Member States during the
justice and Home Affairs Council in June
they intend to reach an approach to be
negotiated with the European Parliament
home affairs ministers in their turn
have migration issues at the top of
their agenda following the tragic events
in the Mediterranean in April EU leaders
agreed to mobilize all efforts to
prevent the death of more people at sea
and to address the root causes of
migration in May the European Commission
presented a communication defining
immediate measures to prevent human
tragedies by strengthening the EU
presence at sea and by targeting
criminals mulling networks fight against
terrorism is also on the agenda ensuring
the security of citizens preventing
radicalization and the cooperation with
international partners are the main
pillars of Europe's counterterrorism
efforts the council will evaluate the
progress in the implementation of
anti-terrorism measures